a day to celebrate Kenya's KTN TV
broadcaster which is part of the
standard Media Group has joined the
German African co-production eco at
Africa the Eco at Africa program
provides a broad platform for issues
such as wildlife protection pollution
and climate change in Africa and Europe
the issues and the environment are so
critical because this really is
impacting only on how citizens of this
country need and often enough we don't
have enough information in terms of what
we're doing with the environment we
believe that this magazine will go a
long way in terms of enhancing knowledge
information and the capacity of people
to make better
Nigeria's channels television is already
a co-producer of eco at Africa they're
also pleased to have KTN is a new
partner on board being here in Kenya in
particular highlights why we need to
work on the environment why we need to
save the planet why we need to all be
doing our bit to make the planet a
better place for everyone to live and
katie-ann
standard group are the partner that's
going to make it a pan-african
pan-african project with Europe in the
form of DW it's really exciting and I'm
so glad to be part of it
Kenya's environmental policies have made
progress it's the only African country
with a climate change act a law
enforcing climate action that has
already benefited reforestation efforts
many local activists are also
contributing to environmental protection
the artist Kyoko movie Turkey for
example turns waste into sculptures he
and other activists will comment
regularly on Kenyan environmental issues
for eco at Africa they'll serve as
environmental ambassadors for the
program people are slowly slowly slowly
losing the values that hold them back to
the past and the values that really
dictate the things they are doing and
how they affect the environment so it's
important that we bring
and the new generation into that
awareness so that we can all be involved
in creating a better world that doesn't
have a lot of ways Eco in Africa is now
presented by two hosts Nyota Egbe from
Nigeria and Edith Kimani from Kenya DWS
marketing manager guido Boomhauer
praised the first African European
co-production of an environmental
programme time to celebrate a new
chapter for KTN channels TV and DW eco
in Africa will continue its coverage of
issues such as green living renewable
energy and the fight against water
pollution
you